[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT'S NOT JUST BUT THAT'S WIT
THE BASE THAT YOU MAKE WANT TO
DANCE.
>> YOU ARE LIKE THE SINGLE GUY
AT THE AIRPORT BAR OR AT THE
WEDDING RECEPTION WHO JUSTICE
AND DRUNKEN UP TO GET UP AND
DANCE.
AND HE BITES HIS LOWER LIP.
>> THE BITING UP THE LOWER LIP.
LAUGH AWAY, YOU'VE GOT A NUMBER
ONE BESTSELLER.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
FIRST, OBVIOUSLY, WHO DO YOU
CREDIT WITH THE SUCCESS OF THE
BOOK QUICK.
>> YOU.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT ME TO SAY?
>> YES.
>> I CREDIT YOU.
YOU HAVE HOW MANY BESTSELLERS?
>> I THINK I HAVE FIVE NEW YORK
TIMES BESTSELLERS.
NINE BOOKS TOTAL UP WITH SOME O
THE TRYING WITH THE OTHER BOOKS.
BUT I DON'T EVER THINK I GOT A
NUMBER ONE.
>> I GOT LUCKY.
MARK LEVIN CAME OUT THE NEXT
WEEK AND CRUSHED ME.
TIMING WAS EVERYTHING.
>> PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS BUT
BOOK PUBLISHERS, ALL THEY DO IS
TRY TO FIND SLOTS AND THE CLICK
YOU DON'T WANT, BUT THIS BOOK
COMES OUT BECAUSE NO ONE IS
GOING TO BUY YOUR BOOK.
>> THEY TRIED TO FIND THE
SLOWEST SLOT OF THE SUMMER TO
RELEASE MY BOOK AND THEY NAILED
IT.
GREAT JOB, BY --
GREAT JOB, GUYS.
WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE PART OF
WRITING THE BOOK?  QUICK.
>> MY FAVORITE PART WHERE THE
MOM TEXTS BECAUSE THAT WAS
ALREADY WRITTEN.
THAT WAS THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
WORK.
>> THAT IS THE BEST.
AT THE END, IF YOU WENT FROM 1-
30 PAGES.
>> I WENT FROM 200 PAGES TO 250
PAGES.
THAT MOMS ARE GETTING ANY
ROYALTIES.
>> I WANTED TO INTERVIEW BILL
O'REILLY FOR RABBI AND I GOT A
COPY OF HIS BOOK.
THAT IS WHAT WE WERE DOING.
HE WOULDN'T EVEN COME TO MY SET
I HAD TO DO IT ON HIS SET.
WHEN I GOT THE BOOK AND I OPENE
IT UP IN THE LAST 90 PAGES OUT
OF 180 WAS AN INTERVIEW WITH
BARACK OBAMA.
IT WAS THE TRANSCRIPT.
>> THIS A LOT OF TRANSCRIPT AND
HOW I SAVE THE WORLD.
>> I SEEM TO REMEMBER THIS FROM
THE O'REILLY FACTOR.
I DID THAT WITH MY MONOLOGUE.
>> MY DAUGHTER, WHO IS 9.5, IT'
VERY IMPRESSED.
THE THAT I BROUGHT BACK BUT IT
THAT IT WAS OVER 300 PAGES.
THEY SAID HOW MANY PAGES.
>> I SAID 300.
THEY ARE LIKE YOUR PRO 300 PAGES
.
>> FOR THEM THAT IS A LOT.
TO ANY FIRST AND AUTHOR, THAT I
THE OBSTACLE.
IS A STOP THE FIRST PAGE.
IT'S WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BOOK
AND I DON'T THINK IT IS POSSIBL
TO DO THAT.
THAT IS WHAT I THOUGHT.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU CAN PUT
THE THING TOGETHER.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
WHAT HAPPENS IS AN OUTLINE DOES
EVERYTHING.
AND ALSO BIGGER FONT AND DOUBLE
SPACING.
THAT WILL TAKE YOU ALONG WAY.
>> I HAVE A GREAT IDEA FOR YOUR
NEXT BOOK.
KILLING "GUTFELD!".
>> THAT WILL SELL.
>> I'M ACTUALLY KILLING MYSELF.
IS A DAILY HABIT.
>> I SHOULD WRITE A BOOK ABOUT
YOU.
>> IT WOULDN'T SELL.
>> YES, IT WOULD.
IT WILL JUST BE ALL TRANSCRIPTS.
BECKS YOU KNOW YOUR NEXT BOOK IS
, HOW I SAVE THE WORLD PART 2.
>> CATCH HE.
>> YOU DIDN'T SUCCEED.
>> I DIDN'T SUCCEED.
>> IS CALLED HOW I SAVE THE
WORLD AND YOU CAN GET IT
ANYWHERE.
MOTHER'S DAY AND FATHER'S DAY
ARE COMING UP NEXT YEAR.
>> I TOLD THEM.
THAT IS WHY YOU NEED BU